Transcriber: ÖZGE İŞBECER
Gözden geçirme: Esra Çakmak
Evet, konuşmamıza başlayacağız sanırım.
Öncelikle hepiniz buraya geldiniz
ve beni dinlemek için zaman ayırdınız.
Bu zamanınızı bana verdiğiniz
için çok teşekkür ediyorum.
En kıymetli olan şeylerden biri
ve en önemlisi zaman.
Ben sürdürülebilir sanat yapıyorum.
Sürdürülebilir sanat aslında
benim için iki anlamı var.
Öncelikle nesnenin sürdürülebilirliği
ile ilgili bir mevzu.
İkincisi ise sanatın sürdürülebilirliği
Ben bu iki tanımı bir arada kullanarak
sürdürülebilir sanat tanımını ortaya atan
belki ilk kişiyim, ilk sanatçıyım.
1999′dan itibaren yani
22 yıldır sanatla uğraşıyorum.
Sanatla yatıyorum, sanatla kalkıyorum.
Bütün yaşam biçimim bunun üzerine
kurulu ve bu hikâye üzerinden
ilerlemeye çalışıyorum.
Tabii bu konuşmalara başlamadan önce ya
da hikâyeme başlamadan önce öncelikle
mücadeleyi hiç ama hiç elden bırakmayan
annem Behiye Sağdıç’a teşekkür ediyorum
ve inanılmaz bir usta olan, zanaatkar
olan ve inceliklere sahip olan babam,
rahmetli babama çok teşekkür
ediyorum Ahad Sağdıç’a.
Sürdürülebilir sanat tanımı nedir?
Bugünlerde çok popüler olan bir konu.
Ne demek bu?
Dünya aslında inanılmaz bir şekilde
hızlı bir akışın içerisinde.
İnanılmaz bir tüketim var, inanılmaz bir
üretim var ve sürekli olarak alıyoruz,
atıyoruz, kullanıyoruz, bilincimiz var
yok arasında gidip geliyoruz
ve bir çılgınlık hâli içerisindeyiz
ve aslında dünyanın o tüketimini, o
kaynaklarını bilinçli ya da bilinçsizce
kullanmaya çalışıyoruz ve bunun bir
tanımını da ortaya koyamıyoruz.
Sürdürülebilirlik aslında bugünlerde
popüler bir konu ve ben 2000'li yıllarda
işte ileri dönüşüm, geri dönüşüm diye bir
şey var ya da çok fazla tüketiyoruz.
Gerçekten bu tükettiğimiz şeylere
ihtiyacımız var mı?  Neler yapıyoruz?
Neler yapmalıyız konusuyla ilgili sürekli
olarak düşünmeye başladım.
Çünkü bir sanatçı olarak bir
yerden başlamak lazımdı.
Diğer kişiler gibi ben de alıyorum,
ihtiyacım var mı?
Yok mu? Düşünmeden kullanıyorum.
Kullandıktan sonra atmaya başlıyorum ve
aslında o zamanı ve nesnelerin
bitmemişliğini görerek bir şeyler
ortaya koymaya çalışıyoruz
ve aslında kendi kişiliğimizi ve
kimliğimizi inşa etmeye çalışıyoruz
bu attığımız şeylerle ya
da aldığımız şeylerle.
Tabii ilk önce dedim ki kendimi
düzeltmem lazım.
Yani nasıl olacak bu?
Herkes gibi
alıyorum ve atıyorum,
kullanıyorum ve atıyorum.
O zaman ben bir sanatçı isem
ve bunu görmeye başladıysam
ve çok fazla tüketim varsa
ve bu tüketime bir şekilde dur demek
gerekiyorsa
ve bunu dur demek için de
bir adım atmak gerekiyorsa
ilk önce
kendimi düzeltmeliyim diye yola çıktım
ve kendi atıklarımı
değerlendirmeye başladım.
Herkes gibi pantolonlarım vardı, dolabımı
açtığımda denim pantolonlarım vardı
ve baktığın zaman işte maviden
siyaha beyaza 8-10 tane pantolon birikmiş.
Evet yazın ve kışın
kışlıklarımızı ayırıyoruz.
Giydiklerimizi, giymediklerimizi
dağıtmaya çalışıyoruz yerine yenisini
koymaya çalışıyoruz ve bir döngü
içerisindeyiz sürekli.
Aslında zamanımızdan verdiğimiz o
nesneleri alıp alıp atmaya başlıyoruz.
O zaman dedim önce kendi dolabımdan
başlamalıyım ve bu atık dediğimiz şeyleri
atık olmadığını gösterebileceğim
bir hikâye yaratmalıyım.
Bu bir ham madde çünkü neticede diye
düşünerek sanki o bir boyaymış gibi
kullanmaya çalıştım ve ilk eserlerimi
yapmaya başladım.
Yaklaşık 2 yıl boyunca atölyeme kapandım
ve 2 yıl boyunca bir pantolondan
nasıl eser yapılırı araştırdım.
Tabii şöyle bir şey var.
Bu eserleri yapmaya çalışırken
şunu fark ettim.
Sıfır atık diye bir mevzu var.
Bu sıfır atık dediğimiz şey ne?
Bir nesneyi, herhangi bir durumu herhangi
bir yerde olabildiğince son anına kadar
kullanmakla ilgili bir mesele.
Dolabımı açtığımda, o pantolonları
aldığımda bunları nasıl kullanabilirim
ve nasıl, neye dönüştürebilirim diye
araştırmaya başladım ve farklı farklı
eserler yapmaya başladım.
Olabildiğince pantolonları aldım.
Teker teker ilk önce paçasından
başlayarak işte
bel kemerleri, düğmeler, şeritler
aklınıza gelebilecek her yerini
kullanarak sanat eserleri
yapmaya çalıştım
ve 2 yılın sonunda dünyada daha önce
yapılmamış sekizden fazla tekniği
uyguladığımı gördüm.
Arkasından şimdi evet,
bir sanat eseri ortaya koyduk.
Atıklardan oluşan bir sanat eseriydi bu.
Tabii ikinci bir problem daha vardı.
Sanatın sürdürülebilirliği
ile ilgili bir mesele.
Bu mesele nedir?
Sanata baktığımız zaman şöyle
bir tanım ortaya çıkıyor.
İki türlü mesele vardı.
Öncelikle nesnenin sürdürülebilirliği,
ikinci tanım ise sanatın
sürdürülebilirliği ile ilgili.
Biliyorsunuz ki sanat eserleri müze
ve galerilerde sergileniyor.
Sadece müze ve galerilerde sergilenmesi
demek aslında insanların oraya çok fazla
ulaşamaması demek.
Ben bir sergi açtığım zaman şöyle
bir hikâye ile karşılaşıyorum.
2 yıl, 3 yıl kadar bu sergiler için
çaba sarf ediyorsunuz,
emek sarf ediyorsunuz.
Bir düşünceniz, bir fikriniz var ve bu
fikir üzerine yoğunlaşıyorsunuz
ve bunları, bu fikri insanlara
anlatmaya çalışıyorsunuz.
Ama sanat öyle bir hâle gelmiş durumda ki,
hepinize soralım.
Yılda kaç kere sergiye gidiyorsunuz?
Kaç kere sergiye gidip oradan
herhangi bir bilgi ya da
bir ışık yakalayabiliyorsunuz?
Böyle baktığınız zaman belki bir ya da iki
kere sergilere gidilen bir durumun
olduğunu gördüm.
Yani aslında müze ve galeriler beyaz küp
hâline gelmiş
ve bu beyaz küp
şu hâl şu noktaya evrilmiş:
Sanat anlaşılmaz, elitist ve yukarıda bir
yere konumlanmış ve bu yukarıdaki tanımdan
dolayı insanlar o sanata
ulaşamamaya başlamışlar.
Bu noktada şunu düşündüm, sanat eğer
insanlar sanata ulaşmak için çaba sarf
etmiyorlarsa ben sanatı insanlara
nasıl ulaştırabilirim
ve burada aslında çok önemli
iki nokta var.
Bunlardan biri sizin çok bildiğiniz
tükettiğiniz gündelik tüketim nesneleriyle
çok anlaşılmaz ya da algılanamaz
eserler yapmak değil.
Olabildiğince sizin bildiğiniz nesnelerle,
kumaşlarla, düğme atıklarıyla, plastik,
karton vesaire.
Her gün gündelik olarak kullandığınız,
temas ettiğiniz nesnelerle sanatı inşa
edersem o zaman dedim ki bir yakınlık,
bir temas kurabilir izleyiciler
ve işte ilk sorun şuydu;
zaten müze ve galerilere kimse gidemiyor
ve kimseye ulaşamıyor.
O zaman ben bu sanatı insanların her gün
ulaşabileceği, görebileceği,
temas edebileceği, gündelik hayatının
içerisinin bir parçası hâline
getirebileceği lokasyonları yaratabilir
miyim diye düşündüm.
Bunun için ne yapmak gerekiyordu?
Öncelikle sanatın alanını
değiştirmek gerekiyordu.
Daha sürdürülebilir mekanlar
kovalamak gerekiyordu.
Bunlar ne olabilirdi?
Hemen araştırmaya başladım.
Evet, mesela tekstil fuarları, söyleşiler,
kongreler, paneller, metrolar,
havalimanları, hastane ortamları.
Burada insanların çok olduğunu gördüm ve
hiç durmadan bir sirkülasyonun olduğunu,
günlük yaşantının içerisinde sanat
eserlerine ulaşabilecekleri mekanlar
olduğunu keşfettim
ve dedim ki ben madem nesnelerin
sürdürülebilirliğine dikkat çekmek
istiyorum, ben madem ki sanat eserlerini
insanlara göstermek, bir farkındalık
yaratmak istiyorsam, aynı şekilde sanatın
da sürdürülebilir olması için yeni
mekanlar kovalamam gerekiyor ve bu yeni
mekanları insanlara anlatmam gerekiyor
ve sanatın aslında o kadar korkulacak bir
durum olmadığını insanlara göstermem
gerekiyor diye düşündüm
ve ilk olarak yaklaşık on iki tane fazla
ülkede tekstil fuarlarına giderek orada
sanat eserlerimi göstermek için normal
kartela ve stantların olduğu bir alanı
tamamen bir sanat galerisi
ortamına çevirdim.
Normalde 15 yıl boyunca edindiğim izleyici
kitlesini bir günde edindim bir fuarda.
Yani 80 bin izleyici kitlesine ulaştım.
Bu şu demek oluyordu; eğer sanatı
ulaştırmak istiyorsan demek ki
kalabalıkların olduğu yerlere gitmek
durumundasın ve bu şekilde farkındalığı
arttırmak istiyorsan eğer onlar sana
gelemiyorsa sen sanatı onlara taşımalısını
anladım ve ben bu şekilde sanatın
mekanıyla oynamaya başladım.
Sergileme yöntemiyle oynamaya başladım.
Sürdürülebilirliğini sağlayabileceğim
bir dil yaratmaya çalıştım ve sanatı ilk
defa kurumlarla işbirliği noktasına
sürükleme durumunu yakaladım.
Yani şöyle bir durum var.
Sanat yaklaşık
20 yıldır belki daha fazla,
size sürekli olarak şunu söyledi.
Sinemayla, radyoyla, işte, fotoğrafla,
görsellerle, “Tüket!”
Kişiliğini ve karakterini
oturtmak için daha fazla tüket.
Reklamlarda, işte kadınlar ya da erkekler
vesaire güzel arabalar
ama bunların aslında hepsi sanat dilini
kullanarak “Tüket! Tüket!” tanımını
ortaya koydu.
Bu sefer dedim ki sanat
tam tersini yapabilir.
Tüketmeden önce tekrar bir düşün!
Gerçekten buna ihtiyacım var mı?
Gerçekten bunu atmak durumunda mısın?
Belki bu başka bir şeye dönüşebilir mi,
sorusunu sordurmaya çalıştım.
Bütün eserlerimde portreler var.
Portreler olmasının sebebi ise sadece
insanı insana anlatmanın en direkt yolunun
insandan geçtiğini düşünen
bir felsefeye sahibim.
Eğer insana bir noktada temas etmek
istiyorsan, iletişim kurmak istiyorsan
göz teması kurmak zorundasınız ve bu
eserlerimin hepsinde size bakan portreler
vardır ve çok uzaktan baktığınızda onları
klasik yöntemlerle yapılmış
bir yağlıboya gibi algılarsınız.
Yakınlaştıkça onun aslında bir yağlıboya
olmadığını görür ve yakınlaştıkça onun
gündelik bir tüketim nesnesi olduğunu
görmeye başlarsınız.
İşte bu noktada sizin kafanızdaki
ön yargılar, ilk önce sergileme mantığı,
arkasından nesnelerin sürdürülebilirliği
ve arkasından sizin kalıplaşmış olan
düşüncelerinizi yıkmaya
yönelik bir adımdır
ve yaklaştığınızda sizin her gün
temas ettiğiniz gündelik
nesnelerle karşılaşmış olursunuz.
Burada aslında söylemek istediğim en
önemli şey şu; ilk önce bir şeyler yapmak
istiyorsanız bu hikayenin kurgusunu
başından sona düşünmeniz gerekiyor
ve adımlarınızı sağlam bir şekilde
teker teker atmanız gerekiyor.
İlk önce bir fikri inşa etmeniz lazım.
Fikri inşa ettikten sonra
araştırmalarınızı yapmanız lazım.
Tüketimin nerede olduğu,
üretimin nerede olduğu.
Bunu çalıştığınız alanla
birleştirmeniz lazım.
Birleştirdikten sonra bu alanları nasıl
daha yaygın hâle getirebileceğiniz
açıkları yakalamanız gerekiyor
ve öncelikle bir sorununuz olması
gerekiyor ki çözüm bulasınız ve çözüm
bulduğunuz noktada da yeni bir
dil oluşturabilesiniz.
Ben olabildiğince sorunu görüp yani zaten
iki sorunum vardı, çevre ve doğa
ve sanatın işleyiş biçimi ve bu iki soruna
nasıl çözüm bulabilirim diye yola
çıktığım bir hikâye
ve işte olabildiğince farklı atık
türlerini kullanmaya çalıştığım
bir hikâye.
Yaklaşık yirmiden fazla atık
türü bunlar ne var, işte;
karton, alüminyum, plastik,
kablo atıkları, kablo bağları, poşetler.
Aklınıza gelebilecek her türlü tüketim
nesnesini sanat eserine dahil ederek
hikâyeler oluşturmaya devam ediyorum
ve bu tekniklerin hiçbiri de zaten daha
önce dünyada kullanılmadığı için de
farkındalık boyutunun arttığı
bir hikâyenin başlangıcını
sağlamaya çalışıyorum.
Beni dinlediğiniz için çok
teşekkür ediyorum.